when something goes wrong I freeze up
opposite of the ogre I freeze up I get
stagnant I don't want to move I just ask
myself why me I've tried saying good but
it's not getting me moving forward any
advice you ask yourself why me
so saying good that should fix your
attitude but that alone
that will that alone will not fix your
problems if you're having problems too
sure say good that's perfect but then
don't ask yourself why me instead ask
yourself now what am I going to do about
it
what are you going to do about ask
yourself that question and then figure
it out figure out what you're going to
do say to yourself I am going to detach
I am going to assess the situation I am
going to come up with a plan and I am
going to execute and then start moving
it's it's not going to be a perfect plan
but take action action that moves you in
a positive direction and if it ends up
being the wrong direction that's fine at
least you've learned where not to go now
where this gets tough is if it is
something that seems like it's
completely out of your control and you
know what some things are completely out
of your control and that's fine
and when that happens
you ask yourself what can I control what
can't I control that will make this
situation a little bit better and then
you go don't get crushed by things going
wrong ask yourself what am I going to do
and then go do it